hey everyone welcome back to another
video by simply lon
in today's video we'll be learning all
about the most basic infrastructure of
react.js core components without delay
let's begin and look at what's in store
for us so we'll be touching on topics
like water components types of
components nesting components higher
order and pure components and a brief
description about component lifecycle
alright to begin with what exactly are
components components are the building
blocks of react application wherein each
component represents a part of the user
interface now to make it more
understandable consider the Facebook
homepage the entire UI can be broken
down into several elements say we have
the credentials component the signup
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the
homepage looks alright reusability is
one of the salient features of react
components one component can be reused
several times across the application and
this improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels the
component can also receive properties
from its parent components also you get
a better understanding of all these when
we start working hands-on so don't worry
so moving on let's look at the different
types of components first we have the
stateless functional components and then
we have the stateful class components
now functional components are typical
JavaScript functions that return HTML
now they can be contained in a dot GS or
a dot JSX file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
HTML they can also be contained in dot
J's or dot JSX file ok then let's go
ahead and build a first react
application using components all right
so I've opened my text editor that is vs
code to be my application also I suggest
you watch the reactants
on Windows video to help you get started
the video briefly explains how to
install node and how to start building
your first tree at application in my
case I've opened a folder called react
component tutorial and here in my source
folder I have app dot J's now app dot
J's is the main component that gets
rendered to the Dom let me show you that
here in index torches you pass app dot
chess which is a component that gets
rendered to the reactor so after J's
consists of several other components
that can be nested so as you can see
after J's is a functional component and
before moving on let me get rid of all
the unnecessary code so let me delete
all of this and return an h1 tag that
sees hello welcome to super let me save
it and if you look at the browser you'll
have hello welcome to central on now
let's go ahead and display another
message say h1 this video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser it gives you an error
so JSS uses a conventional rule which
states that all HTML tags have to be
enclosed within a div tag so for example
I same diff and I enclose it so let me
save and check my browser again here you
go so multiple HTML tags have to be
enclosed within the div tag moving on
let's create the first functional
component to do that I'll first create a
folder in my source folder say
components within that I'll create a
file save functional component torch a s
alright so the first thing you have to
do is import react so I say import react
from yeah the generals and tags for a
functional component involves the
keyword function and save functional
component now you say return and h1 tag
or I've already used h1 tags so I'll say
paragraph and I say this is a functional
component all right
before explaining to you how these
components are exported and imported let
me show you the general syntax for a
class component so I create another file
say class component dot J s I again
import react from react the general
notation is using the class keyword
followed by the name of the class
extending from the base class the active
component so going ahead is a class
class component extends react dot
component now the key feature of a class
component is the usage of a render
method so I say render within braces I
say return a paragraph tag saying if
this is the class component all right so
moving on let's see how these components
can be nested into the main component
that is app table GS components can be
nested into the main component using
import and export keywords so as the
name suggests export features used to
export a particular file or a module and
import is used to import a particular
file or module into the current existing
module so we have two different types of
exports you have default export and just
export or named export so a default
export is used to export just one object
be it a function a class available from
the file and there can only be one
default export per file and when you are
importing it you can specify the address
and use the word import before it so let
me show you how it works let's go back
to our editor and then functional
component and here I say export default
and the name of the function company
that is functional so let me save this
and going back to my app dot J's I say
import name of the functional component
that is functional comm from and I pass
the path this confidence slash
functional component also let me get rid
of these unnecessary files here
now let's define functional company
dinner apt objects component so here I
see functional comm let's compile it and
check our browser here it says this is a
functional component moving on to my
class component it's the same syntax
here as well I say export default name
of my confident and in my ab dot yes I
important import class come from the
path and again I'll have to define it in
my return method I say so let me compile
it
and check my browser it says this is the
class component one unique feature of
default export is that I can rename the
file while I'm importing it so for
example I can rename it as say FC and
while I'm defining it I'll have to make
sure I use the same naming conventions
as I say FC again when I check it it
says this is the functional component
there is literally no difference the
next type of export is the named export
or just export so a named export can be
used to export multiple objects be it
functions class etc from a file now
there can be several named exports from
a single file one hack is that while
your important it cannot be renamed so
let me show you how this works
okay so let's create another class in
our class component so I'll just copy
paste this let me give it another name
say class comp 1 and the message that I
want display is hey I'm another class
alright so when I'm exporting it I don't
want default so let me take it off and
say export here alright in my app dot
J's while importing it I want to import
both the classes so I'll include them
within curly braces here I say class
comm comma class comp 1 and then again I
define it here class comp 1 let's
compile it and run it and here we go
here you can see hey I'm another class
so we've successfully exported both the
classes from the class component and
imported it back in our app dot is
confident one advantage of using named
export is the fact that I can choose to
import the classes that I want to now
say for example I do not want to import
class component here so let me take it
off and here let me comment
now let's compile and see here him
another class the second class got
imported while the first class I was
defined earlier is not imported here
alright so next up we have higher order
and pure competence now I won't get into
the net abilities of it because they're
advanced topics but to give you a brief
insight higher-order components are
basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher-order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic ok so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component click dot GS alright
so here we define a class I use this
snippet or seee here we go we get the
entire format using the small snippet
RCE
and here I'm going to make use of a
button now say I use the time button and
I'll say clicked one every time the user
clicks on the button the value gets
incremented so for this I am going to
use a variable sake count and I'm going
to use the concept of states so let's go
ahead and define our variable count and
initialize it to 0 so for that I'm going
to use another snippet called our
constand here this dot state equals my
variable count initializing it to 0 so
let's define the pound variable in a
render method so I see Const count
equals this dot state so every time we
click on the button the count value has
to get incremented right so we make use
of an event called on click equals this
dot update okay now update click is
going to be another method that we have
to define now so every time the button
gets clicked this method is called so
let's go ahead and define the function
so it is update clip equals is going to
be an arrow function and I say this dot
set state is nothing but count this
take dot count plus one okay and sure we
see competence alright so once this is
done let's import a component in app dot
J's so here again I say import click
from components tip and let's define it
here so let's check our browser every
time we click on the button the value
gets incremented alright so let's go
ahead and create another component say
counter door GS where in every time the
user hovers the mouse on the button the
count value increases so let's go ahead
and do that
I say counter dot GS and again going to
use the snippet RCE
to create a class component and here in
my div tag I define a button and say
incremented to 4 now I see X so now
let's go ahead and add the event say
button on Mouse enter I'm going to call
the method this dot increment count okay
so once you're done with that let's go
ahead and define the increment count
method I'm going to copy the same code
that I've mentioned in my clipped ojs so
I say copy this alright so one change is
that I change the name of the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
I say Const count equals this top stick
and here I change X to now let's go
ahead and import it in our app dot J's
so I say import counter from components
and counter and let's define it here all
right let's save it and let's run the
code ok so as you can see you see
another button here incremented to zero
and every time I move my cursor on the
button it increments mind you I'm not
clicking
I'm just hovering my mouse okay to learn
how higher-order components work will
have to pass counter door chase and
clicked or chase as parameters to give
birth to an entire new component so for
that let's go ahead and create another
component for our hoc let's call it
higher-order
GS okay so I see import the act from
yeah after that I think Const updated
component equals original component
that's going to be an arrow function
again and within curly braces I define
my class that is class say new component
extends react dot component inside let's
define a render method that returns the
original component with a modification
that is I want to type the user I want
to append the user before the actual
message is displayed alright so let's go
ahead and close the tag and return new
component and let's export this say
export default updated component now we
import higher-order door chairs in our
counter dot J's and clicked or Jess and
passed these components as parameters so
let's do that lets go to our counter dot
yes and here i say import updated
component from dot slash higher order
competent and here while exporting I say
updated come and pass this as my
parameter let's do the same to clicked
or chase here I import data come from
higher-order component and here the
fastest as a parameter now here in a
higher-order component we have define a
property name and initialized it to the
user so we'll have to include this in
our other components that's counter and
click so let's do that
and here right before incremented to I
say this dot props dot new let me save
it let me do the same thing here and say
this top props dot so if you go back to
our browser here you can see it says the
user clicked zero times and the user
incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoid unnecessary rear
Enders now how does it do it it does not
element the should component update
method now you learn about this method a
little later in the video now this
method enables rear-ending of components
to the Dom but a pure component on the
other hand and show us a shallow
comparison of States and props and
checks a few rerender is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the Dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example I'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a pure component or J's
file I save your form dot J's so here
I'm going to use a snippet our pce that
is going to create a pure component
class let me get rid of this export and
here in my div tag I will display the
text say alright now let's go ahead and
create a regular company I may call it
and here I'm going to use a snippet RCE
and the message that I'd wanna display
is I'm the regular component so to draw
a comparison between the regular
component and the pure component let's
create a parent component for the two so
let me create one here I'll call it
parent component or chairs and this is
again going to be a regular class
component and here I display the message
I'm the parent complained to change the
state of the component we're going to
make use of a constructor so let's use
the snippet our Const and here let me
create name you can give anything and I
say simply lot now we make use of the
component did mount live cycling method
to set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're gonna learn about it a
little later in the video
so moving ahead I'm going to make use of
the method and say component did mount
and here I say set interval the first
argument is going to be an arrow
function and the second will be the time
interval and I'm going to be setting it
to 3 seconds now within the arrow
function I'll
Q's of the sad state function to set the
state of my property however I do not
change the name and keep it simply done
itself moving on let's import your
component and the regular component into
a parent component and then pass name as
a property so to do that first import
your comm from your component and then I
say import regular come from Telecom yes
and sure let's say regular name equals
this state say pure component state
taught me now let's include the property
name in both our regular and pure
components so to do that let's just save
this dot dot name and here again save
this and finally let's import parent
component into our app dot J's component
so here I say import parent okay so now
if you look at the browser we have I'm
the parent
I'm Doug low component simply lon and I
am the pure component simplygon we've
got the result as expected now to check
if the pure component is actually easy
rendering or not let include simple
console dot log statements so here I say
CLG snippet here I say pure component
render and in my regular component I do
the same thing I say let's do the same
in our parent component as well alright
so let's go back to our browser and
inspect it in our console first the
parent component gets rendered then the
regular component and then the pure
component after that for every three
seconds only the parent component and
the regular component is rendered so the
same state and drop the pure component
is not read entered
so in conclusion pure components
optimized react codes and also improves
performance so coming to the last topic
component like
cycle so basically comprehend lifecycle
explains the stages the component goes
through the entire lifecycle of a
continent can be divided into three
parts
we have mountain updation and unmounting
so the first thing that gets invoked in
the lifecycle is component will mount it
is invoked right before the initial
rendering occurs then we have the
rendering method now once a component is
inserted into the Dom component did
Mount gets involved coming to the next
phase we have updated when a combined
receives props component will receive
props gets invoked such state is called
when the state of the property changes
so every time there is a change react
decides whether the next component state
should trigger a rerender or not to do
that should component update method is
called component will update is invoked
right before we're entering after the
rendering company did update us call it
that makes updates to the Dom and the
last phase is unmounting component will
unmount method does all the necessary
cleaner and it raises all the allocated
memory and cycles all right so that is
it for this video we'll be coming up
with content on props and state so watch
out for that until then keep learning
and stay tuned to simply long hi there
if you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here